now it's been a successful commonwealth
games for england this year currently
second in the medal tally with more than
40 goals but
one athlete who's really stood out is
freestyle swimmer tom dean who recently
became england's most decorated athlete
at a single commonwealth games winning
a total of well he's here tom dean is
here tell us how many it is well i can
see them yeah so it's seven medals all
in uh six silvers and one gold medal
well congratulations look at that hall
it practically takes up the whole sofa
absolutely how does it feel to have
made this extraordinary record no it's
incredible and it was about halfway
through my week of racing where
um i started to ask a question actually
how many is the record
and then we did a little bit of digging
and it came out there was six was the
most decorated english um athlete across
all sports uh for total meadow hall and
and i realized i had seven races all in
so if everything went to plan and you
know the stars aligned then then i'd be
able to hit that magical seven and you
know it's still slightly you know
slightly overwhelmed still now you know
even when you just read out there it's
absolutely incredible
so even though you knew it was possible
was it ever really in your expectations
do you think um it was always in the
back of my mind i didn't want to jinx it
though you know i didn't want to say it
too early um but it was always in the
back of my mind and the thing is there's
so many variables you know everything
has to go perfectly the races have to be
executed perfectly and when i'm doing
the relays you know you're relying on
three other people to execute the best
race to get that medal so
a lot of things had to go right and
luckily they did and particularly sweet
the last one was the gold the last one
was the gold yet so six silvers and i
was chasing that gold the whole time and
a few of those silvers were really
really close races and and finally you
know to win on that relay and i was i
was doing the final leg of the relay the
anchor and it was just the perfect
ending to the week oh very exciting and
tell us a little bit about your your
rivalry with duncan scott i mean
how does that affect your performance do
you think is it actually helpful to you
do you think um i can't seem to get away
from the guy honestly um no i think we
didn't invite him today yeah true true
the first day i've got away from him um
no it's it it is great we're really
great mates you know in and out of the
pool but that rivalry is is you know so
so tight um so my my medley uh swim for
example i think he had me by twelve one
hundredths or thirteen one hundredths of
a second so you know it's so so close
fine fine margins but i think we do push
each other on as well you know um
because we do similar events both in the
same country you know we were one and
two at the olympics last year in the 200
freestyle so we're always you know
getting the best out of each other and i
mean it's an extraordinary result after
what i'm sure has been a lot of build up
and training and hard work give us a
sense of what is involved in preparing
for games like this yes it's a year-long
preparation ultimately so we finished
the olympics last year i took a small
break and then it's straight back in you
think about the next one so it is a full
you know 11 months of training and
that's 10 swim sessions a week four gym
sessions a week we're doing core we're
doing you know stretching sessions in
the round it's you know 30 plus hours a
week of training and that's for 11
straight months so
finally when you get to competition
that's almost the best bit because
you've done the hard work and you can
just focus on the racing but then it
becomes about executing those perfect
race plans you know doing exactly what
you've been working on in training yeah
and and making all that training count i
guess and not not um wasting that
opportunity
and so what now do you get a rest now do
you get to kind of long lines and not go
near a swimming pool that would have
been nice but actually i was back in the
water uh yesterday training so we we did
the last race on wednesday and then i
was back in the the training hub in bath
back back to training because we've got
the europeans next week so we fly out to
rome on monday so it is very much back
to back and and we're straight back into
another block of racing but then luckily
i get a break before we start the next
season and is that a good or a bad thing
having them so close together do you
have a sort of momentum do you feel
going from one event on to another so
quickly yeah absolutely and especially
when you've got good results behind you
you know i know i do well out in uh up
in birmingham so i know i can just carry
that good form on to to rome um when you
have a slightly longer break you know it
you have to kind of train and then and
then come back down and rest back up but
with this you just bounce straight on
and you just straight back into the next
one you just carry those you know your
sharpness and like your race readiness
into the next one well that's
interesting because i mean how much is
it about
feeling physically tired or not and what
about mentally tired as well i mean is
it quite difficult to be that focused
over so many events um in different
places absolutely it is tough and and
one thing that um i think sometimes
swimming fans
or swimming spectators don't quite
understand is even though you're adding
one extra race that means you're adding
a heat a semi and a final so three more
races you've got to get up for so even
though i did you know seven um seven
medals that's like 11 or 12 swims all in
so you're having to get yourself up for
it physically emotionally you get to the
end of the week it's just like you're
completely drained so it is quite
demanding and that's why i think you
know having a big break after europeans
is something that's really important and
something that people have started to
wake up to the fact that it can take in
a bit of a mental toll as well
so and so you will take a break oh yeah
i will i can't wait i've got uh yeah a
good four weeks off and i'll be able to
switch off you know have those long
lines get away from the pool for a
little bit because you know ultimately
we're two years away from paris and it's
going to be a tough two years of
training and you know that's the big
focus
of course that's that's so that's coming
up relatively soon isn't it absolutely
and what about your reaction back home i
think your your mum threw a rather
famous 3am party didn't she when you
were competing in tokyo you won the gold
medal that was it yep absolutely and
that that that's legendary
how have they reacted this time so
luckily they were actually able to come
up to birmingham to watch me this time
which was really special no yeah 3m
garden parties with me on the other side
of the world um you know and then
watching on a big the big projector
screen yeah they're able to come up
which is great i saw them after every
race which was absolutely brilliant and
you know when i get back from europeans
we're going to have a big celebration
big big summer party and you know i'll
be able to have all my family and
friends they'll be really special so
what difference has it made now that
we're out of a pandemi which which must
have played havoc with a lot of the
competitions yeah the competition time
with training as well you know the big
impacts on our training um
birmingham crowd i was just saying
earlier i've never ever experienced
anything like it it was unreal five
thousand fans in the sandowell aquatic
center all on their feet you know
whether it was like a heat session on
day three or the big final session on
day six they were just absolutely
bouncing so when i won that relay got my
seventh medal you know reached you know
the most decorated english athlete and
one that you know the the final race the
whole me it was just absolutely electric
i've never ever experienced anything
like it and why do you think that was do
you think it's partly because everyone
was so happy to be back watching
competition again abs 100 you know been
starved of live sport for two years and
and you know swimming especially it's
just it's just not the same without that
crowd so everyone's come back you know
home games to to win at the end it was
just you know the support for the
english swimmers was incredible well
huge congratulations it may take you
some time to pick up all your medals
and leave the studio but uh thank you
for bringing them in and uh what an
achievement tom dean really loved to see
you thanks very much